Another key point is that you don't need any
extensive knowledge of biology or genetics to take this course.
>> The Udacity team has worked really hard to
make sure that this class is accessible for everyone.
Ideally, you'll have some exposure to high school biology
but event that's not necessary. Now if you need resources
to help you out where you're in the course,
there are two main places for you to look. The
first is in the section titled Instructors' Notes. And
that's where we as your instructors will post relevant information
to the concepts and topics that you see in the videos. The
other important section is called Discussion Forums. And this is where you
and your fellow classmates can actually post links to topics, or questions
that you want to talk more about. For example, there is a discussion forum
on this page entitled the meaning of life. And I've put a
permanent link to it in the instructor's notes on this page. Now
I want you to click on that link and go see what
it says because you're going to need
the information to answer the following question.
What is the answer to life, the universe, and everything?